It shouldn't be too hard to figure out the answer in this case.
All you have to do is try these examples that I've got here with these functions.
The one that works is this floor log base 2 of x plus 1.
If you don't know what the log base 2 of x is, well, that's essentially what it is
that we're learning about here.
Log base 2 of x is easy to define for powers of 2.
It's just what power of 2 it is.
The log base 2 of x is 0 for 1, 1 for 2, 2 for 4, 3 for 8, and 4 for 16, and so on.
What's happening in this case is the log base 2 of x is something less than 2 up until here.
We round it down. We get these as--
Well, let's do that. Let's do the floor.
That gives us 1, 2, 2, 2, 3, 3, 3, and so on.
We need to add 1 to it to capture this notion.